[Música]
buenas tardes
estaba pensando cómo empezar porque yo
ni bailo ni nada ni hago estas cosas tan
guays que he visto por aquí pero tengo
una historia que contaros que quizás no
sabíais y resulta que aquí mismo donde
estamos ahora hace 13 mil 800 millones
de años nació el universo
ni más ni menos
todo lo que es todo lo que ha sido y
todo lo que será que es lo que decía
carl sagan sobre el universo todo lo que
es lo que ha sido y lo que será estaba
aquí hace 13 mil 800 millones de años
luego ya todo lo demás nosotros nuestro
planeta nuestro sol los otros planetas
las otras estrellas las galaxias toda la
materia que vemos y la que no vemos todo
estaba aquí exactamente hace 13 mil 800
millones de años y esta es una historia
muy poderosa que la sabemos gracias a la
ciencia y la sabemos gracias a que hemos
mirado al cielo
he ido pasando aquí y posiblemente
debería haber mirado aquí
había había puesto 13 mil 800 millones
de años para no olvidarme de la de la
cantidad pero bueno da igual esta es
esta historia me gusta contarla y lo
llevo haciendo y ni siquiera es mía las
buenas ideas además no tienen no tienen
una sola madre tienen muchísimas
personas y es algo que nos hemos ido
dando cuenta a lo largo de muchísimo
tiempo cuando mirábamos el cielo he
tenido la oportunidad al fin al cabo de
contar esta historia y otras en sitios
increíbles este es un cielo del
hemisferio sur una noche una noche fría
en el salar de uyuni en bolivia tuve la
oportunidad de sentirme volar por el
espacio porque las estrellas que había
encima de nosotros se reflejaban en la
salmuera y ese cielo nos contaba
historias de las personas que habían
vivido allí en los andes' durante miles
y miles de años y habían mirado al cielo
una noche también tuve la oportunidad de
estar contando esta misma historia
o una más o menos parecida en la que
quizás cambie los años o alguna cosa de
estas
en la sierra muy cerca de las trincheras
de atapuerca por allí pasaban hacía casi
un millón de años los primeros europeos
y miraban un cielo y se harían preguntas
también como nos hacemos nosotros cuando
miramos recuerda unos años más tarde
frente al eje o
oscuro en el mar azul intensísimo del
mediterráneo estaba la isla de lesbos
allí ahora no hay quien mire al cielo
desde luego pero allí también nos
preguntábamos y nos mirábamos y decíamos
somos parte de esta historia del
universo que hemos mirado y que seguimos
mirando lo cierto es que desde muy
antiguo hemos mirado al cielo y nos
hemos hecho preguntas
hemos ido pintando hemos ido dibujando
hemos ido cartografiando nos hemos
imaginado los dioses los mensajeros de
las estrellas de los espacios siderales
hemos hemos realizado los mapas hemos
mirado sus movimientos hemos aprendido a
contar el tiempo a hacer nuestros
calendarios a hacer nuestros relojes
hemos hemos plantado mirando al cielo un
montón de líneas y de orientaciones que
nos nos han permitido navegar por todo
el mundo hace más de 2000 años en la
polinesia mirando las corrientes marinas
y mirando el cielo
se hacían navegación es desde nueva
zelanda hasta hawai y luego los europeos
aprendimos a navegar y cruzar el
atlántico y darle vueltas al mundo hace
poco más de 500 años hace 400 años
aprendimos además a preguntarnos mirando
al cielo por la razón de todo eso que
había detrás nació la ciencia moderna
con el uso del telescopio es decir con
nuevas tecnologías y sobre todo con el
impulso de muchas personas que no se
quedaban contentos con las explicaciones
que habían escuchado de antes que
estaban en los libros poderosos y
sagrados se hacían nuevas preguntas y
allí estábamos de repente descubriendo
mundos
entendiendo por qué se movían esos
mundos imaginando de que eso de que se
componían
mirando más lejos mirando más
profundamente y descubriendo un universo
que en cada momento se nos hacía más
sorprendente pero en el que empezábamos
a sospechar que todo funcionaba de la
misma forma que funcionaba en la tierra
si los antiguos se habían imaginado que
los cielos eran algo muy diferente ahora
teníamos la oportunidad de empezar a
sospechar que todo todo seguía unas
reglas que estaban escritas en algún
lado y en un lenguaje lleno de
matemáticas
cuando cuando pudimos mirar más lejos
nos hemos ido encontrando con
imágenes sorprendentes esta es una
imagen muy especial que se obtuvo con
miles de horas de observación de uno de
los más potentes telescopios que hemos
realizado los humanos
el telescopio espacial hubble y apunto a
una zona donde no hay ningún objeto de
nuestra galaxia este campo ultra
profundo nos estamos mostrando un montón
de puntitos que veis aquí y cada uno de
esos puntitos es una galaxia pero no una
galaxia como la vía láctea como la
nuestra que tiene 12 mil millones de
años de historia sino una galaxia que
está
las galaxias que están muchísimo
muchísimo más lejos y es que aquí viene
una de las grandes sorpresas con las que
nos hemos ido encontrando cuando
mirábamos al cielo
y es que mirar al cielo es mirar al
pasado
si estamos viendo la luna hoy cuando
salgamos vemos ahí a la luna brillar ya
estamos viendo como era hace poco más de
un segundo
estamos viendo el sol tal y como era
hace 8 minutos cuando los fotones
salieron de su fotosfera y empezaron a
viajar los 150 millones de kilómetros
que nos separan de nuestra estrella
cuando estamos viendo el cielo una noche
estamos viendo estrellas cuya luz
viajo desde hace años centenares de años
o incluso miles de años cuando estamos
mirando el cielo no solamente rompemos
esa idea antigua de la esfera celeste
sino que nos encontramos con un espacio
que además es la historia propia de ese
universo que estamos mirando cuando
estamos mirando más lejos estamos
mirando mucho más atrás estamos yéndonos
por lo tanto al comienzo o casi al
comienzo de todo es decir estamos
mirando aquí aquí mismo a pesar de que
miramos
tan lejos es un poco paradójico pero
pensad en todas estas galaxias cuya luz
se ha ido viajando desde hace doce mil
millones de años
son galaxias que vivieron son conjuntos
enormes de estrellas nubes de gas y
polvo que vivieron en un universo que ya
no existe estudiarlas observarlas nos
permite de la mano de la ciencia
evidentemente con las tecnologías que
hacen esto posible nos dan los datos
para poder entender cómo era ese
universo pero necesitamos la teoría
necesitamos la física también
necesitamos ir más allá el problema es
que lo que nos va explicando lo que
conocemos del universo es que al
principio era muy denso era muy caliente
era opaco
la luz no podía viajar por el universo y
entonces los astros físicos
que yo me dedico a la astrofísica
intento explicar qué es eso que estamos
viendo nos quedamos un poco así como
diciendo que podemos hacer si ya no
podemos ver más lejos no podemos llegar
a ver la historia no podemos ver los
primeros capítulos de la vida del
universo como siempre las tecnologías
la tozudez humana de decir vamos a
intentarlo y la casualidad nos vinieron
en ayuda
y dices bueno tanto esperar para esta
imagen
este es un mapa pero vamos a decir que
es una foto es un mapa mundi es el mapa
del universo es la imagen de cómo era el
universo cuando tenía solamente 380 mil
años es decir justo al poquito de nacer
y entonces en esta imagen vemos que
estaba todo funcionando como funciona
ahora es decir las leyes de la física
funcionaban tal y como las conocemos y
ese día el universo sitio transparente y
la luz empezó a viajar y cuando miramos
con los telescopios como esto es una
imagen del telescopio planck de la de la
gds europea del espacio nos vamos
encontrando con esas luces
bueno aquí codificado en color estamos
viendo cosas que están ahora muy frías
porque el universo se ha ido expandiendo
y entonces estamos viendo que y entonces
había pequeñas agrupaciones
allí es donde fueron naciendo las
galaxias donde primero nacieron las
primeras generaciones de estrellas y
otras más y otras es decir estábamos
viendo en esta imagen lo que no podíamos
ver
una de las grandes sorpresas de esta
búsqueda con la que miramos al cielo de
la mano de la ciencia es que podemos
irnos encontrando como en este caso con
algo que pensábamos de hecho que no
podíamos ver algo parecido pasó hace
unos pocos años con el descubrimiento de
las ondas gravitacionales que nos han
hablado también de objetos tan
inconmensurables que ni siquiera emiten
luz pero si podemos ver sus efectos o
como esta imagen que se obtuvo
el día de abril del año 2019 esta es una
versión mejorada que se ha publicado
hace poquito y que quizás visteis no es
el agujero negro central de una galaxia
que está muy lejos de nosotros y que se
llama messier 87
poniendo el trabajo conjunto de
diferentes radio telescopios radio
observatorios en todo el mundo poniendo
de la mano el trabajo ingente de
teóricos de físicas y físicos prácticos
de astrónomas y astrónomos
y de la mano de las máquinas y de la
inteligencia artificial porque esta
ciencia no se puede hacer sin grandes
colaboraciones se conseguido obtener
esta imagen una imagen sorprendente que
si no nos lo explican no sabríamos que
es porque es un objeto que se traga todo
incluso la luz y que está cayendo y
materia y es parte de ese universo
sorprendente que nació aquí mismo os
recuerdo hace 13 mil 800 millones de
años
todas estas conjeturas todas éstas
bueno búsquedas incansables se están
repitiendo y se están haciendo cada vez
más intensas pero necesitan de algo
necesitan del espíritu humano de la
colaboración de muchas personas de
países diferentes
una mirada al cielo que ya no solamente
es la que tenemos nosotros desde un
salar en en bolivia o desde atapuerca o
desde el egeo
es una mirada que necesita precisamente
de esa búsqueda común que estamos
haciendo en los últimos años y que es la
que nos está permitiendo entender un
poquito mejor el universo en cierto modo
estamos volviendo a lo que decía al
principio miramos al cielo y vamos
construyendo edificios maravillosos
que nos permiten entender cómo nació
todo aquí y en todos los sitios que
conocemos del universo hace 13 mil 800
millones de años hoy nos hemos juntado
aquí con un lema precioso que además me
ponía a mí en bandeja el poder hablaros
de estas cosas y contaros estas
historias y era universe
sin embargo la ciencia la observación
del cielo requiere no solamente de
grandes telescopios de telescopios
espaciales de misiones no solamente
requieren además de grandes trabajos
teóricos de la física y de entender algo
que podremos explicar en el futuro por
ejemplo una de las cosas que no podemos
todavía explicar y para la que os pido
ayuda es porque todo esto que estamos
viendo
solamente es un 4% de todo lo que hay
nuestro universo es así así de malvado
todo lo que hemos estado viendo todo lo
que hemos visto en estas imágenes no es
sino la luz de una materia que es el 4%
de todo el universo
hay más por ejemplo desde hace decenios
sabemos que unas seis veces más un 23
por ciento de todo lo que es lo que ha
sido y lo que será está compuesto de una
materia que no emite luz le llamamos
materia oscura precisamente el nombre no
es terriblemente original pero nos sirve
para pensar que esa materia está ahí es
decir atrae a las cosas de hecho ahora
sabemos que las formas que tienen
nuestras galaxias y otras galaxias la
forma que tiene el universo como una
especie de espuma llena de huecos y con
muchos grupos de galaxias todo eso tiene
que ver precisamente con la abundancia
de la materia oscura en el universo
desde el año 2000 tenemos además la
confirmación de que materia visible y
materia oscura no son sino una cuarta
parte de todo lo que es en el universo
el resto a lo que se ha llamado en la
energía oscura y la vemos ni sabemos qué
es
y cómo funciona del todo pero está
produciendo que todo se esté expandiendo
que cada vez estemos más lejos del resto
del universo en las escalas enormes que
tiene vivir pues unos 13.800 millones de
años
entendámonos bueno para resolver estas
preguntas o estas dudas que os estoy
contando hoy nos hace falta más gente es
decir tenemos que saltar del universe
a los winnie vers
somos todas y todos todos los que
estamos aquí los que tenemos que
intentar solucionar y para ello tenemos
que seguir
mirando al cielo les quiera unirse
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
a
[Música]